die Notfallaufnahmen in deutschen
Kliniken häufig sind sie überlastet zu
viele Patienten zu wenig Personal die
Wartezeiten teilweise lang auch weil
nicht jeder Patient in der Notaufnahme
wirklich ein medizinischer Notfall ist
doch wie können Notfallaufnahmen
effektiv entlastet werden
Bundesgesundheitsminister Karl
Lauterbach will die Notfallversorgung in
Deutschland reformieren denn die
Gesamtzahl der vom Krankenhaus
behandelten Notfallpatienten stieg von
14,9 Millionen auf 19,1 Millionen 2019
eine Zunahme von 28%
. ich bin sicher dass wir dieses Problem
was er seit zehn Jahren besteht dass er
auch dieses Problem lösen können das
gehört zu den vielen Problemen die in
den letzten Jahren immer wieder also
benannt worden sind wo aber noch keine
Lösung gefunden worden ist
die Notfallaufnahme im Klinikum
Osnabrück vor allem tagsüber herrscht
hier Hochbetrieb eine Frau hat Schmerzen
im Unterleib erste alamnese durch die
notfallpfleger
Blut wird abgenommen der Blutdruck
kontrolliert Fieber gemessen wie schnell
braucht die Patientin einen Arzt und
welchen welcher Patient hat
möglicherweise Vorrang das Entscheiden
erstmal die Pflegerinnen und Pfleger
Abstufungen von Rot sehr dringlich bis
hin zu blau die haben sehr viel also
müssen halt sehr lange warten teilweise
bis der Arzt sie sieht war die
Beschwerden schon seit langer Zeit
bestehen wenn ihr zum Beispiel sagen die
haben die fuse Bauchschmerzen können wir
entscheiden ob das der allgemeinchirurg
sehen muss weil es gegebenenfalls
Blinddarmentzündung sein sollte oder ob
die Rückenschmerzen haben dann z.B auf
den Nierenkolik ist oder sowas denn dann
hatten wir bestimmt den entsprechenden
Fachrichtungen zu jeder Patient der in
die Notaufnahme kommt wird nach einem
triage-system eingeteilt das hilft dem
Krankenhauspersonal die Patienten Ströme
zu organisieren in der Notfallaufnahme
ist solch ein System unerlässlich
erklärt Chefarzt Lars Roman Herder
das System ist ja dafür erschaffen
worden dass wir dass man generell davon
aus geht dass wir nicht so viel Personal
nicht so viel Kapazitäten zur Verfügung
haben um alle Patienten sofort zu
versorgen und
Patienten die in eine niedrige Kategorie
fallen das sind in der Regel Patienten
die dann an die Notdienstpraxis
weitergeleitet werden
einmal zur notdienstambulanz diese
Notdienstpraxis liegt nur wenige Meter
von der Notfallaufnahme entfernt im
selben Gebäude hier hatte sich die Frau
mit den Bauchschmerzen zuerst
vorgestellt Hausarzt andreas raming hat
heute Dienst die kassenärztliche
Notfallsprechstunde wird über einen
Verein organisiert raming und seine
Kollegen sind Anlaufstelle für
medizinfälle aller Art zunächst mal hat
der Patient einen Ansprechpartner für
die ganze Region Osnabrück er weiß hier
ist eine Praxis die hat immer dann
geöffnet wenn der Hausarzt geschlossen
hat vornehme ich natürlich auch am
Wochenende und an Feiertagen
er weiß hier wird er aufgenommen
behandelt und wir haben auch die
Möglichkeiten weitere Untersuchungen zu
veranlassen in Kooperation mit der
Klinik die Ärzte die hier freiwillig
Dienste übernehmen bekommen ein normales
Honorar für die Behandlung das
Leistungsspektrum umfasst die
körperliche Untersuchung Sonographie und
EKG auch eine labortechnische
Untersuchung kann hier erfolgen für
Patienten wie Lisa mit kleinen Anliegen
eine gute Sache ich wollte erst zum
Hausarzt aber der hat ja bekanntermaßen
mittwochnachmittags zu und man ist dann
immer auch ein bisschen unsicher ob der
Fall schlimm genug ist um jetzt wirklich
so in die Notfallambulanz zu gehen
deshalb habe ich auch vorher angerufen
ob das in Ordnung ist da man ja auch die
ja Wartezeiten für andere Patienten und
Patientinnen nicht unnötig länger machen
möchte aber ich war ja auch schon mal
und für mich immer gut aufgehoben und
deshalb war ich froh dass ich dann
schnell kommen konnte die
Patientenaufnahme des Krankenhauses
teilt die Menschen die selbstständig
hierher kommen je nach Anliegen direkt
den Abteilungen zu entweder geht es von
hier aus zur kassenärztlichen
Sprechstunde oder in die Notfallaufnahme
dieses Zusammenspiel zwischen Praxis und
Krankenhaus ein Beispiel wie Kooperation
und Entlastung im Gesundheitssystem
funktionieren können es ist eine
Möglichkeit die Patientenversorgung in
Deutschland neu zu strukturieren was
jetzt empfohlen wird meinen wir dass das
eine gute Lösung ist die
Patientenversorgung zu verbessern die
Wartezeiten zu reduzieren und auch den
Patienten der Einrichtung zur Verfügung
und
zuzuweisen der das am besten auch regeln
kann
die notfallstruktur in Deutschland soll
verändert werden eine
Regierungskommission des
Gesundheitsministers arbeitet derzeit
Vorschläge aus
die Regierungskommission Krankenhaus hat
ein sehr guten Vorschlag gemacht wie die
Notfallversorgung in Deutschland neu
aufgebaut werden könnte da arbeiten wir
mit einem Leitsystem auf der einen Seite
auf der anderen Seite auch mit einer
frühen Zuordnung die bereits also bei
der telefonischen Annahme der Fälle dann
zum Tragen kommen soll somit an
zweistufiges System diese gemeinsame
Leitstelle für die Nummer
116117 des ärztlichen
Bereitschaftsdienstes und die
Notrufnummer 112 soll die Patienten also
beraten und den richtigen Stellen
zuweisen wichtig hierfür gut
ausgebildete Fachkräfte und eine
computerbasierte Steuerung
telefonische Beratung braucht auch einen
eine hochqualifizierte Ausbildung um den
Patienten richtig auch zu lenken
gleichermaßen muss ja auch juristisch
abgedeckt werden Gesetze im Fall er hat
sich falsch entschieden und der Patient
erleidet einen Schaden dann muss auch
hier nachgegangen werden inwieweit der
Algorithmus und der andere entscheidende
hier eventuell fehlerhaft gehandelt hat
das muss geklärt werden eine
deutschlandweit einheitliche
Notfallpatienten Steuerung wird für alle
Akteure im Gesundheitswesen eine
Herausforderung allerdings sind sich die
Fachleute einig die Notfallaufnahmen
müssen dauerhaft entlastet werden im
Klinikum Osnabrück ist diese Entlastung
schon spürbar immer dann wenn die nahe
Ambulanz auch geöffnet hat man merkt es
schon wenn jetzt Hausärzte auch ein
Brückentagen zum Beispiel zu haben da
die Notdienst Ambulanz ja nicht geöffnet
und oder halt erst ab 15 Uhr oder oder
sowas da merkt man das schon dass die
Patienten dann einfach auch hierher
kommen weil sie mal Schnupfen mussten
Heiserkeit haben
oder und nicht wer sie wirklich in
akuter Notfall sind oder weil sie
teilweise über Facharzt bei Fachärzten
halt auch sehr lange warten müssen die
enge Zusammenarbeit zwischen Notaufnahme
und kassenärztlicher Notfallsprechstunde
wie hier im Klinikum Osnabrück auch an
anderen Orten gibt es dieses Modell aber
eben längst nicht flächendeckend jedoch
liegen die Vorteile auf der Hand die
Wartezeiten werden verkürzt Personal
entlastet die Steuerung der Patienten
schon jetzt verbessert für die Frau mit
den Bauchschmerzen geht es nach der
Behandlung in der Notfallaufnahme direkt
auf die Station